[Music]
welcome everybody we are gonna talk
about kubernetes and spinnaker and sto
and how we can kind of combine all this
to do multi cloud who's excited come on
all right gke on-prem great
announcements yesterday hopefully
everybody's conference is going well my
name is Amir Abbas I am a customer
engineer here in San Francisco which
basically just means I help people solve
problems in the cloud I've had the
privilege of working with a few of you
actually in the room and few customers
that have either embarked on the journey
to this hybrid cloud multi cloud or are
already there and some of the best
practices that we've learned kind of
together I've kind of consumed then into
this session and maybe over the last
over the next 30 minutes or so forty
minutes we'll talk about that here's my
twitter handle somebody told me i gotta
up my twitter game so I think I have
three followers so hopefully by the end
I'll have maybe five so all right so
what are we gonna talk about we're gonna
talk about multi cloud and why
organizations are going multi-cloud why
is this thing kind of hot and heavy
right now and how does that affect
people's experiences how does that
affect your customers experience how
does that affect your company's your
organization's experience your
developer's experience or operators
experience we're going to talk about
that and then we're gonna talk about
three things we're gonna kind of talk
about the the architecture itself and
just for the sake of this discussion
we're gonna stick with kubernetes
however there are multiple definitions
of multi cloud and hybrid cloud and it
goes beyond kubernetes but what just to
kind of keep stay focused we're gonna
talk about kubernetes and why that makes
it better we're gonna talk about how you
can manage life cycles of your
applications and then just kind of talk
a little bit about after your
applications are up how do you do
connectivity and observability and how
you safely connect those and hopefully
we've seen enough sessions today so
hopefully you guys know kind of where
we're going so let's kind of just start
at a very high level why people are
looking at this thing called multi cloud
and if we kind of step back in time to
the times of data centers I've never
stepped into a data center where I saw a
single vendor
right so you didn't just have Cisco or
didn't just have a single vendor for
servers or single vendor for storage
you always had multiple vendors in there
and that I think trend continues even in
the cloud the only challenge is in the
cloud you have the owners or the cloud
owners that own your data center so in
this case you have to actually double
your data centers or you have to have
multiple data centers and set up the
other way around
so the number one reason what we've
heard in terms of why people go multi
cloud is just this idea of zero vendor
lock-in right
even though cloud provides you with a
lot of resiliency and availability but
if you're using manage services and if
one of those services goes down then
you're kind of you know out of luck
organizations want more control and
every cloud vendor kind of does you know
cost a little bit differently perhaps
you have credits with one cloud and you
want to use those so that you know kind
of comes around a lot resiliency and
availability I was working with a
customer they were in a single region
they decided to go multi region and as I
was talking with them they said the
benefit that they got from going multi
cloud and the work that they had to do
instead of going multi region with a
single cloud versus multi region with
multiple clouds was really not that much
and all those benefits that they got was
you know they they outweighed the work
that they had to do Best of Breed
services is usually another one right so
we want to use multiple clouds because
each cloud is doing something better
than others so at Google we're known for
our data services or our ml and perhaps
you're using you know some proprietary
services on on Prem so the idea that I
want to be able to kind of use and
choose what I want to use and then the
last one comes up maybe not as often and
it's the idea of Technology and business
partnerships you don't want to kind of
hedge your bets with a single vendor and
perhaps you want to have you know
multiple integrations in multiple
environments really kind of it comes
down to in one word choice whether
you're looking at as a business owner or
whether you're looking at it from a
technical standpoint a lot of the things
that we talked about here previously you
can think of them as kind of business
reasons why people go multi cloud or
multi cluster in that particular range
but when we look at it from a
developer's standpoint it really comes
down to freedom of choice right so
developers productivity is directly
correlated to the services that they can
use
and they can choose right so if I'm a
developer and if I want to use bigquery
or spanner or any of the open-source
products or any of the other managed
services regardless of where they're
located I just need a safe passage to
get there and I don't really care how I
get there I just want to be able to
describe what I want and magically it
just appears to me choice leads to chaos
right the more choice you have the more
kind of things are a little bit
different they're heterogeneous and as
operators as DevOps we don't like
heterogeneity right because that leaves
to something unsafe it slows everything
down and we want to be fast at iterating
so the question comes and I get asked
this a lot you know should I be using
platform as a service and it's a great
question right and perhaps you start
with a single platform and even a
platform as a service and then you
decide where you want to go the
challenge in general with platform
as-a-service is they're very opinionated
systems so they kind of go inversely
proportional to the idea of developers
choice right so you may start with a
platform and you may kind of lock your
developers into what they want to do and
then eventually your developers are
gonna want something else and then all
of a sudden you are getting into this
heterogeneous world anyways so this is a
cultural type of a tipping point that
you have to decide where you are at that
particular case let's switch focus just
for a minute to DevOps and operators so
in a very kind of a you know high-level
way our jobs as operators is to take
something that's chaotic and take
something that's heterogeneous and
that's running in these hybrid
environments push it through some magic
box and then outcome something very safe
and sound and homogeneous because we
like that that's what we want to to kind
of get to and what goes in that circle
is what's kind of in our opinion if we
can make an opinion about about that I
want to take a quick segue and talk
about these two words that are in the
middle culture and tooling and I really
want to start with this idea of tooling
whenever a new tool comes out like
kubernetes for example and all of a
sudden it gains a lot of hype everybody
wants to do kubernetes I don't even know
what that means like when people say we
need to do kubernetes it's just became a
verb or something and then we force our
organizations are people or culture to
kind of adhere to that tool I think
we're doing it backwards I think what we
need to do is kind of sit down with our
business with our business goals and
figure out exactly what culture we want
what culture of development we want what
culture of iteration we want what
culture of deployment we want and then
pick the tools that match that culture
and I think that's also the reason why a
tools also get a lot of you know kind of
mixed reviews because what we're doing
is we're trying to use a tool which it
wasn't meant to do and we'll talk about
that here a little bit later so let's
get back to our regularly scheduled
programming so talking about operators
and talking about DevOps here where
developers need more choice and their
productivity really hinges on the
services that they can get - it's our
job to get them there safely
the journey is under our control we
can't really control the destination but
we can control the journey and I think
that's that's our true calling is to
make sure that we give them that golden
path that safe passage there and what
goes in that middle box of automation
and control and tooling that's something
that we can be opinionated about and
that's something we can talk about so a
lot of people ask kind of where all
these pieces fit in right so we have
kubernetes and spinnaker and histy oh
well what does that mean and do I new
need all of these things so this is kind
of a simple visual of where I think
everything kind of fits in right so at
the very bottom you have your business
logic that you convert into code as a
developer and you need a way to package
that and containerization gave us that
and we don't need to really talk
anything more about that I think we've
been talking about that to death so
containerization gives us a great
efficient way to package your code then
as you start deploying containers in
production at scale you need some sort
of an Orchestrator some sort of a
control plane that manages that and
that's where orchestration comes in it's
a way to run your applications now that
you have your applications running you
need to manage the lifecycle of that
applications and that's where CI CD
tooling so continuous integration
continuous deployment and delivery tools
come in and then this last thing which
we're going to talk a little bit more
about later is this idea of now that we
have hundreds maybe thousands of
containers running how do we securely
connect and monitor and manage these the
connectivity of that and that's where
the concept of service mesh comes in and
where these some of these tools
fit in is something that looks like this
we think kubernetes is the best place to
run your containers and we'll talk about
why that is and why it's really gaining
a lot of hype in the developer community
especially spinnaker again is one of
those tools it's a continuous deployment
tool we'll talk about that and
especially we'll talk about that in the
realm of multi cloud and hybrid cloud
and then some of you may have heard of
sto which is an implementation of
service mesh that allows us this kind of
a safe passage from container to
container now two things I want to say
about this picture one I think first of
all I think this forms a very formidable
formidable platform for you right it's
built of open source things that you can
deploy anywhere you don't have to have
every single component that you see here
right you start with something kind of
basic as a matter of fact a lot of the
times a journey starts with just a
platform a kubernetes or an Orchestrator
of your choice and then you just make
sure that you can do that well and you
can do that better before you kind of
move on to these tooling another thing
about this is that a lot of these things
you can slide out and insert your bring
your own Orchestrator or bring your own
CD tool you're not stuck with these
things we're just talking about them as
examples because these kind of fit well
in the multi cloud space but you can
slowly kind of go through this journey
and you can you can exchange these LEGO
pieces to what kind of makes the most
sense to you because I do get asked a
lot of question about spinnaker versus
cloud build and stuff like that and it's
again it's a spectrum it just depends
upon what you want out of your let's say
continuous deployment tool or service
meshes we've been doing them it was just
called routing and switching and
firewalls and why do we need service
mesh that you gain it just depends upon
what you're what you're trying to do so
let's maybe start at the bottom of the
stack and kind of work our way up and
then just kind of see how this all kind
of fits together and then maybe we'll
even talk a little bit about the kind of
the journey of it right so kubernetes in
one sentence it's a way for developers
to describe their workloads and it just
makes it happen through a consistent API
right so it completely abstracts you
from cloud resources your application is
a combination of a bunch of resources
right there's V pcs and routing and
firewall rules and VMs and load
balancers all of that combined your
application is kind of hidden in there
somewhere and kubernetes gives us that
consistent API where developers can just
say
this is what I want done this is my
desired state and what works well with
kubernetes is if you're in heterogeneous
environments or hybrid environments it
will abstract you the way you do
networking on Prem versus the way GCP
does networking you don't have to think
about that as a developer anymore
you can simply describe it in a very
consistent way and it will just make it
happen
as you start expanding you may start
with a single cluster you'll probably
end up becoming multiple clusters
whether it's in single cloud so in this
picture let's say you start with a
single cluster multi-tenant and
eventually you go to multiple clusters
in GCP then you have some clusters on
Prem perhaps gke on Prem and then we
have this one cluster in some orange
cloud that no one's ever heard of so we
start thinking about how we're gonna
manage this right so first concept I
want to talk about is cluster
consistency so the idea is kind of
similar to API consistency with
kubernetes if we have multiple clusters
if we configured them kind of in a
consistent way not only do I get
workload portability but I also get a
consistent way to describe my workload
so if I'm a developer and I can go
around and I'm travelling and let's say
I just want to get to connected to the
my closest cluster I just want to be
able to describe my workload and through
the magic of routing I should be able to
get to where I want to go and kubernetes
gives us this concept of namespaces
which are just kind of these logical
containers and abstraction within a
cluster that divides your cluster into
different kind of containers that you
can put authorization and are back on
top of that so an example here is for
example if I'm a developer perhaps I
have my own namespace and I have some
resource quota within that namespace
where inside of that namespace I can do
whatever I want so I can develop I'm
free to do whatever I want and then
perhaps teams have their own namespaces
like team my development team or my
engineering team and they can
collaborate on top of that so a lot of
people ask the question is when do I
need multiple clusters versus when do I
need namespace separation right a common
theme looks something like this by the
way you don't need eighteen clusters
this was just easier to cut copy paste
three times but essentially an easy way
to think about this is you will separate
out your
phases of development so you'll have a
separate cluster or clusters for dev
separate one for staging separate one
for prod and that's a that's a theme
that we've seen and by the way this is
by no means an exhaustive list of what
you should do this is just some common
patterns that have emerged as we're
talking to people within an environment
so within dev within prod within staging
they look fairly consistent and in this
case like I said I just cut copy pasted
it however you may have you know is much
smaller let's say dev environment and
completely different set of namespaces
and permissions than staging than prod
and you know your mileage may vary so
when you look at a picture like this it
looks quite daunting and then you start
thinking about well how am I going to
manage all of these things and how am I
going to manage applications that go
into all of these things so again going
back to the idea of that when we find a
tool that we get really kind of a lot of
force behind a lot of community behind
immediately we want that tool to solve
all the problems so immediately we say
oh we need some sort of Federation you
know that word comes up and any pretty
much in any technology that I've ever
seen we need Federation and we don't
even think about what that means a lot
of people just say Confederation solve
this problem like we have we need some
networking between this pod in this pod
Confederation solve this problem or we
need cluster management Confederation
solve this problem so we just
immediately want the tool which is not
by the way designed to do what it's what
it's meant to do we want that tool to
solve everything right so kubernetes was
really designed to run containerized
applications at scale in production and
that was it
right and then we started talking about
this concept of Federation right and I
don't mean to kind of you know kind of
talk down on Federation I'm just kind of
delivering the message of kind of how we
typically think as a community and how
we immediately start to expand the scope
of what the products actually meant to
do so Federation for those of us who may
not know is a kind of an API that's
abstracted away from the cluster and it
kind of gives you a centralized control
plane and the hope or the dream is that
that Federation API will imagine just
solve all of your problems from
networking to cluster management to
application management when you think of
a picture that looks something like this
and you really kind of look at
some of the use cases and what are we
trying to do and you split them up it
makes a little bit more sense to see
what tools makes the most sense to solve
the problem so first thing is the
cluster lifecycle management itself how
do I manage the policy and the lifecycle
of the cluster that's one problem then
you have application lifecycle
management how do I manage the
applications that actually get put on
top of that that's another one and then
you have the kind of the service
discovery cross cluster integration and
that problem right and we want
Federation to solve all of these
problems and it may be the right
solution we don't know it may not be the
right solution may be the right solution
what we're starting to see there were a
couple of logistical problems with the
Federation API they were only a handful
of people that were working on the
Federation API whereas versus thousands
and thousands of people that were
working on the the kubernetes api and it
was just almost nearly impossible to
keep that feature parity and on top of
that when you have a centralized control
plan and something goes wrong it just
cascades across everything so when you
make one mistake it just goes through
that so whether you call it cluster
independence I don't know if that's a
really good name I know the community
called it multi cluster just the idea
here is that if you treat each cluster
kind of isolated islands and you just
overlay them with components and tooling
that gives you cluster lifecycle
management that give you application
lifecycle management it might be a
better way to do things because you can
kind of isolate the blast radius when
something bad happens so from a cluster
lifecycle management we're not going to
talk too much about that I know there's
some some announcements coming with with
the GK on prim and multi cluster
management hopefully you saw some of the
demos I'm really gonna go into
application lifecycle management and
then service cross cluster service
discovery and kind of traffic management
piece so let's look at an application
running on kubernetes so again we have
multiple clusters and an application on
kubernetes is also a combination of a
bunch of resources right so you have
deployments and deployments are running
replicas of pods so in this case we have
an application let's say this is a web
front-end application running and two
versions of that deployment running we
have a red version and a black version
three pods running each they're upended
by a service and then let's say this is
a web front-end so you're exposing it
out to an ingress and since this is a
web four and you want that application
running everywhere so the picture looks
some
thing like this you have a bunch of
these resources that are kind of
distributed across clusters across
namespaces and then if you put a box
around all of this that's what your
application actually looks like and from
a developer's perspective I don't want
to go into each cluster and start
looking at what my deployment looks like
what my ingress looks like what my
service looks like so platforms and even
cloud resources in general are a very
resource centric give you a very
resource centric view of your
application they don't really tell you
what your application is doing so hold
that thought when we go to spinnaker
we'll talk a little bit more about that
but I really want to talk about where
spinnaker fits in in this application
lifecycle management and how we CC ICD
at Google so from converting business
logic into source code we have source
repository to building and unit testing
your artifacts and that's where cloud
build kind of comes in hopefully you've
heard some of the announcements around
there too artifact storage through
container registry and that's our own
private container repository very
similar to docker hub that's backed up
by cloud storage and we're spinnaker
really fits in is in the continuous
delivery and continuous deployment thing
right so that's what spinnaker is meant
to do and again this is a spectrum there
are a myriad of tools that you can use
to manage your application lifecycle and
it depends upon where in your journey
are you in that particular stage right
so you can use cloud built to do
everything if you don't need let's say
automated canary analysis which we'll
talk about or if you don't need you know
our back integration with your LDAP and
and stuff like that right so what is
spinnaker for those of you who may not
know spinnaker is it is an open source
tool it was open source by Netflix it's
a continuous delivery and deployment
tool that works really well across
hybrid and multi cloud environments and
by hybrid I mean both in different
clouds let's say on Prem and GCP or
something as well as in different
environments so you could do VMs and
kubernetes it gives you a very
application centric view of your
application so in this particular
example this is a screenshot of one of
the screen shots of spinnaker we have an
application called MD service and you
can see that right at the top left and
then I can see exactly what's happening
with that particular service so that
particular service is running in two
clusters those are the red boxes I can
see which namespaces they're running on
so they're running in the default
namespace
I can see how many deployments
are running so in the the prod version
which is that the top cluster I have one
deployment running which it's kind of
the big box and then I can also see the
the green rectangles are the individual
pods that are running and I can see them
scaling up and down and since they're
green that means everything is nice and
healthy everything is good to go
and in my staging cluster I can see that
I have two pods running and I also can
keep track of my existing iterations of
that deployment also if I click on any
of these resources I can get a much more
detailed view of what's going on so if I
click on the deployment I can see how
many replicas I'm running I can even see
the container logs and so on everything
in spinnaker is deployed in something
called a pipeline which maybe not a
foreign concept to a lot of you which is
if I want to get from version one to
version two I need to go through a
series of steps and actions that are
interdependent and they really depend
upon what's happening before so this is
an example and those steps by the way
are called stages right so this is an
example of a fairly common pipeline
where I've taken something out of
staging and I want to now eventually get
to production that particular piece of
code so I grab that image I deploy it as
something called a canary which we'll
talk about I wait a few minutes and make
sure that that thing is looking good if
everything passes then I promote that to
production I tear down the old canary I
tear down the old production and I tear
down the canary that I've deployed and I
promote that particular image to to
production
even though kubernetes comes with some
elementary way to kind of manage
applications or manage services like
rolling updates and stuff perhaps you
need a little bit more horsepower and
spinnaker kind of gets you that extra
mile right so there are deployment
strategies built in like red black
rollin red black or canary they are the
kind of three more popular ones so red
black or sometimes called blue green is
the idea that I have one version of an
application running so in this case we
have the blue version with eight pods
running let's say and then when I want
to deploy a new version version green I
also will deploy an eight pods and then
I will just flip the load balancer over
great thing is I can very quickly and
immediately move back to the blue
version if something goes wrong and the
bad thing is I need twice as many
resources because I have both versions
running for a period of time so that
kind of gives kind of the new iteration
of that is the rolling
red black or rolling blue green which is
I will gradually roll down one instance
as I bring up the other instance and at
every so often I will just make sure
that everything is everything is going
very smoothly and I'll have these kind
of validation gates and canary is
another iteration of rolling red black
really the idea here is that I will
deploy a canary a very small version and
I will direct production traffic to that
canary and then I will test that canary
for a number of metrics against a
baseline of production traffic and then
based on all these metrics I will give
it a score a canary score and then if
that score is passable or high enough
then I will promote that to to
production and that really kind of what
makes it different is that canary
analysis piece and the idea that I'm
actually sending production traffic and
I'm actually comparing it to prediction
baselines some other things that are
built in or just the idea that I can
dictate which days and times I want
these pipelines to run I can have manual
intervention so I can say you know go to
step C and then pause and then let's
wait for someone to actually push you
know push the continue button and I can
rollback quite easily because spinnaker
keeps track of historical views of
what's happening as well lots and lots
of integrations these are just a bunch
of logos triggers are a good one so you
can trigger pipelines so you can have
all these templated pipelines already
built for each application maybe even
multiple pipelines and you just need a
way to trigger them so an easy way is
any time a code changes or a version tag
changes and I'll show you an example of
that shortly just run the pipeline so
think of that pipeline as kind of that
paved path to you know to your the next
version let's talk a little bit about
sto and service meshes right so we have
kubernetes deployed we feel very good
about about just our kubernetes
environment then we started deploying
some sort of a CD tool or CI CD maybe
spinnaker and we feel great now we have
multiple versions of our applications
and services running in multiple
environments and all these need to now
talk to each other and we don't know
exactly how to do this right so somebody
smart said this still don't know who
said it but I think very very wise words
by somebody is I have no idea how it
everything is talking to each other and
more importantly I can't observe exactly
what's going on in these particular in
this particular thing and that's kind of
where SEO comes in and before we talk
about sto let's spend a few minutes on
service meshes and what is a service
mission why do we need it and I was
trying there was a pretty big long
sentence and then I was just trying to
keep it short and short and this was
kind of the shortest form of that
sentence which is transparently
automating Network application functions
or even more simply I want to basically
take the business logic away from any of
the networking functionality all right
so any anything to do with networking
security observability I want to
abstract that away from my my pour code
my core business code that's really what
a service mesh is lots and lots of words
on this slide this is not my favorite
slide you don't have to read it but just
the four categories that we just kind of
want to mention now that we have
multiple versions of multiple services
running we want to be able to control
which version of service a can talk to
which version of service B which user
can talk to which front-end and so on so
we we need some intelligent and more
advanced routing than what kubernetes
natively gives us resiliency timeouts
circuit breakers is a huge one if I have
cascading failures I wanna be able to
open that circuit for X amount of time
instead of just that service going
haywire health checks security and
policy is a is even bigger right so
every service needs to have some
verifiable form of identifying itself to
other service so when two services talk
to each other I want to be able to tell
with great confidence that I am Who I am
who I say I am and I want to be able to
talk to each other in an encrypted
fashion and then policy enforcement
perhaps I want to to put limits on you
know RPS and QPS and how many you know
how much how much rate can one service
talk to another perhaps you have a free
version or freemium freemium version of
a service and you can say I'm going to
rate limit that and then you have a paid
version and you can open that up and
then last probably should be the first
which is the idea if I also want to
observe and see exactly what's going on
so I want to see the logs and the
metrics and especially distributed
tracing which really kind of comes into
being when you're talking about multiple
clusters so a quick history of load
balancers Matt Klein wrote a fantastic
blog on medium if you haven't seen it I
highly recommend it it's a little bit of
a long read
and I'm sure we'll share these slides
with you but it's or you can just type
Matt Klein history of load-balancing I'm
gonna give you the three-minute version
of what he talks about on kind of where
we were and where we are now so the idea
again is very simple if you look at the
the kind of the top two top two versions
of load-balancing they're fairly similar
is that I have a bunch of clients that
want to talk to a bunch of services a
bunch of back-end services so I go
through a single gateway a centralized
gateway or a proxy like an f5 let's say
in the data center or something like
that and then it fans out my requests
back which means everything has to talk
to that centralized gateway alright so
that second one is kind of an iteration
of that maybe internal load balancer
versus external the challenge with this
and that's what we call server-side load
balancing right the challenge with this
is in a microservices environment where
every service needs to talk to every
service you're paying that extra hop so
if everything is going to a centralized
gateway that model may not be the most
efficient it may work again for a period
of time and then eventually it'll grow
beyond that and then you're paying that
extra hop so that's where the concept of
client libraries came about which is
again I'm going to take anything that I
need for networking and I'm going to
shove that into a library and then I'm
going to force my developers to use that
library with every service that they
create so it works great day one you
have one language and you have one
version of the client library and use
force your developers that do a very
good job and then all of a sudden you
have multiple versions of that library
and one language and then all of a
sudden you have multiple languages and
multiple versions of that library and oh
by the way developers are not networking
experts are not security experts so any
of the vulnerabilities that you have
they are just going to blindly put that
into their services and you have this
very tight coupling between services and
that networking functionality so that
kind of gave birth to this idea of that
I want to take all of this networking
and security and observability and I
want to run that out of process out of
my core service process as a sidecar or
as a think of it as a valet so instead
of you talking directly to me you will
talk to a valet and then say go ahead
and deliver my message right so now we
have an interesting picture just at the
bottom by the way this is what's called
client side load balancing where I've
taken all of the load balancing and
routing
switching functionality and I've moved
it out of procs out of process now we
can draw a line in between those two
services and we can have clear
delineation of roles and
responsibilities above that line is my
business logic my developers can handle
that that's what they're good at let
them do that below that line our
operators or network admins or DevOps
can handle that that's what they're good
at also it gives the there's the
services at this point have no idea of
their networking topology which works
great in this multi cloud hybrid cloud
heterogeneous environments that we're
talking about so a way to look at it is
you have a bunch of services and they
each have a sidecar
running and visually if you think about
two semi two kind of concentric circles
you have an outside circle with all
these services and then you have kind of
an inside circle with all these proxies
outside circle has no concept of the
inside circle or any of the topology you
can even just pick that up and put
another one in and these proxies are the
ones that are talking to each other and
the developers are just kind of sitting
on the outside just developing and just
putting you know business logic into
code so that's one way of looking at it
another interesting thing about this
picture is it looks very clean you have
this kind of a box around these two
things so in this world of
containerization these two could be
containerized and it should be put in
some abstraction and in kubernetes that
works really well because we have
something called pods that can run one
or more containers so in this particular
case we have one container running our
service and then one container running
our proxy or our sidecar and that's
where that kind of concept comes in so
what does that proxy anybody's heard of
Envoy all right half the people great so
envoy is a proxy at its heart at its
core it's just a layer four proxy just
like nginx h a proxy it has layer seven
filters built in it can speak a lot of
different protocols it's HTTP to first
it's very scalable very resilient it's
very lightweight right so the
lightweight part makes it really
interesting and really efficient to to
work in that by the way you don't have
to use envoy but I just mention that
because it does a few things pretty
interesting so the way you configure
envoy at runtime is through something
called discovery services and together
they're called aggregated discovery
services or 80s so listen our discovery
service what ports should I be listening
to and how should I be listening to them
discovery services how should i route
traffic as it comes in and goes cluster
and endpoints you can almost think of
them as services and pods in the
kubernetes lingo so a cluster is a
service in kubernetes and endpoints or
pods or endpoints with in kubernetes and
they can discover that at runtime live
they don't have to be restarted the
proxy doesn't have to be restarted which
now brings us to sto sto is just an open
source implementation of a service mesh
you don't need sto as long as you have
something like that it still gives you
uses those envoy proxies and gives you
all that kind of network functionality
and from an architectural perspective
what it looks like is something like
this and for the past few minutes we've
been talking about the data plane how
the actual data flows back and forth so
in this particular case every service
even if it's outside of kubernetes will
run with a out of process proxy so in
this case this is the Envoy proxy that's
running right below each service and the
service will never talk directly to
another service it will go through its
sidecar proxy through the other sidecar
proxy and then back up and then it's
between the proxies is where all the
networking magic and all those advanced
feature functionality in telemetry all
of that is happening and services have
no clue of the networking topology much
like everything else we need a data
plane which we talked about in a control
plane the control plane consists of
three components the pilot the mixer and
the Citadel and let's talk about each of
these at very high level the pilot is
the deployment or the service that
actually configures those Envoy proxies
so it talks to every single Envoy in
your service mesh and says this is how
you're constructed this is how you need
to talk to each other it has kind of a
north sight on the south side and we
kind of talked about the south side
which talks to the to the envoy API so
it uses the those aggregated discovery
services to configure the envoys itself
and then on the north side it uses you
know other service discovery services
like it uses the kubernetes api to
discover all the services running it
also uses sto configs which are custom
resource definitions to actually where
you can configure yourself the route
rules where you can say I want you know
50% of the traffic going to version one
and 50% to version two it discovers all
of that and then pushes that down to to
the envoys themselves so it's
responsible for just configuring the
Envoy proxies mixer is kind of the
pluggable
it does two things it does policy and
quota enforcement and it does telemetry
collection itself it's just a collector
it's not a log logging solution or a
metric solution it's an API that exposes
these metrics out to something right so
from a log from an observability
perspective those proxies by the way are
sitting at a very fortunate position
because they get to see every single
request to go through them and they can
asynchronously send all these fancy
metrics to something in this case that
something is the mixer and then you can
plug in your own solutions and your own
tooling to app to abstract I'll leave
all of these you know metrics and then
display them however you want so for
example Prometheus has a plugin which
comes as a part of an sto implementation
prometheus is a metrics collector that
connects through mixer collects all the
metrics and then you can put some
dashboarding solutions like de fauna or
something else stackdriver has a plugin
where you can do all of those things in
in a single place it also does policy
and quota enforcement so you can have
you know you can have rate limiting and
and so on and so forth and then Citadel
is the last piece and that does all the
security stuff right so it provides
verifiable identity in the form of
spiffy IDs and then it also provides a
mutual encryption so the the Citadel
list sort sort of like a CA or a
certificate authority where it's
responsible for distributing
certificates revocation and you know
collecting that so this is where I just
want to show you kind of an example of
how this kind of all works and let's
pray to the demo gods that everything
everything is kind of working on that
can we please switch to demo I was told
not to have screen savers okay so just
to kind of set the stage on where we are
we have three clusters three kubernetes
clusters they're all running in GCP we
have two clusters one in central one in
east that's going to kind of simulate
our multi cluster multi cloud deployment
and then we have a third cluster that's
just running our spinnaker so it's just
responsible for just sending
applications down there I'm just going
to show you just an example of a web app
it's a very simple web app that takes
the version tag from the application
name and puts it back into the
index.html file so we can just always
see what's running and then we
can just curl that application so if we
just do and I'm just gonna pick one of
those two clusters but it's essentially
the exact same thing so if we look at
the deployments on the central cluster I
have two deployments running so I always
have a canary running and then I have my
prod running and the version changes
depending upon your the version next is
always canary in the version now is prod
and I always have four pods of of prod
and one pod of canary running so what
I'm gonna do right now is just start a
kind of a curl loop so you can just kind
of see what's what's going on so
currently in my GK central cluster I
have in my app which is just a web
front-end and it's running version one
zero three in production and now I'm a
developer and I want to upgrade that and
I don't really care about kubernetes or
spinnaker or Sto I just want to upgrade
this thing so I'm just gonna simulate
that all I'm gonna do is change the
version tag of the same application
because it will update the application
itself so I'm gonna go from version one
zero three to version one zero four just
written right here so if I go here and
I'm just gonna open a second window so
we can keep that curl loop going and
it's a single command it's a container
builder command so it takes that
container and it just updates the
diversion tag of that same container but
imagine you know in your mind that
you've actually made some code changes
and then you've updated the version tag
so it's successfully uploaded and let's
look at what's happening in spinnaker so
this is my app that's the same
application that's running I've already
done some some iterations to that and
you can see that the last iteration was
version 103 so I've set the trigger to
kick this pipeline off every time the
version tag updates so let's look at
that pipeline and that pipeline look
it's a very simple pipeline and you'll
notice there's two roads and they both
look very identical because it's just
deploying to East and Central at the
same time so the first thing it does is
it deploys the new version as canary to
both clusters with one pod then it tests
the canary and it the way it does that
it is just simply just downloads a curl
utility busybox and just curls that
service and if it's up great and then it
stops and then it says there's a manual
judgment stage where it says do we want
to promote and promote this to
production and then when we say yes it
promotes
to production and the way it gets
triggered is just down here you can see
it's a web server and every time this
tag changes this V tag changes go ahead
and trigger it so if we go back you can
see that the pipeline is already
triggered four one zero four and each of
these boxes is representing each of
those stages so the first two boxes are
Central and East canary the next two
boxes are testing the central and east
canary and then it stopped at that fifth
box right if I if I just kind of hover
over that you can see that it's it's
asking me to hit continue so at this
point what's happening is I have four
pods of version 103 deployed as
production and then I have one pod of
version 104 deployed as canary so let's
look at our cloud shell and what you
notice right off the bat is that we're
still going to to production and that's
because I have sto installed on this
cluster and I've explicitly said that
send 100% of the traffic to production
so again I'm a developer I have safely
deployed this thing with a single
command I didn't have to worry about
kubernetes deployments or spinnaker but
now I want to send some traffic to it
and just for the sake of the demo what
I'll do is I'll send 100% of the traffic
to canary so I'm just going to copy a
route rule I'm gonna delete the drought
rule that says send 100% to production
and then I'm going to implement another
route rule that says 100 percent of the
traffic send 100 percent of the traffic
to to canary and if we look at that
route rule it's a very simple route rule
that just says look at that label on
that deployment and if that label says
that canary just go ahead and send 100
percent of the traffic over and now if
we go back we should shortly see that
thing move to 104 and I don't need to
worry about calling a networking admin
or something and now 100 percent of the
traffic is going there and and then now
I can control these weights and then
perhaps I want to send you know 5% 10%
20% of the traffic without talking to
anybody so let's say I you know I mean
just to show you another example so
let's say we want to send 50 50 so I can
go back I can delete the the 100 canary
rule and just put a 50/50 rule and if we
look at what our out rule looks like now
basically by using the magic of labels
and saying anything with the label of
stack prod send 50 percent of the
traffic anything with the label of stack
Canaries and 50 percent of the traffic
if we go back to that
you'll start seeing that traffic kind of
go back and forth but my ideal state so
let's say that we're happy with this the
ideal state is I want to go back to 100%
of do you know tube 2 production traffic
so again I can just delete that 50/50
rule and put that 100% production
traffic back in now I'm happy with my
deployment I'm gonna go ahead and hit
continue and I'm going to promote
version 104 to production so those last
two boxes are essentially doing a
kubernetes deployment backed by the same
service and they're deploying four pods
of that and while they're deploying we
can actually look at that application
and what it looks like today and so this
is in the middle of it deploying to
production so we can see that version
104 there's one pod deployed as canary
and then in production I'm starting to
now create another deployment for
version 104 but in the same screen I can
see it tearing down the canary and
putting a new version up until it's
ready these are gonna be red until it
waits for every single pod to be ready
before it makes them green so let's go
back to our pipeline and let's just make
sure this last one finishes that is the
central one and once the central one
finishes what we're hoping and expecting
to see is that version 104 first of all
becomes prod the new Prada and then 100%
of the traffic goes there of course that
one is the one that's taking a little
bit of time so so right now
you can see that the difference here
from the start of the demo was we had
103 as prod then we had 104 as canary
and now we have 104 as prod so just
using spinnaker and sto and kubernetes
together as is from a developer's
experience perspective I just want to
deploy my my work load and I want it to
safely go from you know from testing to
canary to production and I want to be
able to manipulate how I want that
traffic routed so I was able to show
that can we switch back to the slides
please so that was the demo and thank
you so much for your time that's all I
had I know we have about seven minutes
so I will take some questions until they
cut me off so there's any questions
please come up otherwise thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]